it's time to check in with las vegas now
host mercedes martinez and she's joining
us live from the mix 94.1 studio good
morning mercedes
good morning heather so good to see you
and you as well this story just warms my
heart you know it was what about two
weeks ago when you shared with us that
really powerful story of your dad and
how he helped a group of strangers get
home after their flight was grounded
during the 9 11 attacks
and you recently got in touch with one
of them
yes it was hard to believe i reached out
on social media and one of those
passengers joyce blood
got back to me and it was an emotional
reunion
for seven hours i wrote in a van
with six people i don't know their names
i couldn't remember any of them but i
always remembered him it's kind of the
story family story on 9 11.
where were you you know everyone says
where were you on 9 11. well i could
tell you exactly where i was
and i will never forget it i mean how
can you ever forget that
it was a difficult memory for joyce she
was actually grounded in omaha while
traveling to
to chicago to visit her sick mother she
didn't know what to do until this
happened
i started to walk down the hall which
was just
massive people
and there was this man and he held the
sign up
and it was like oh my gosh
that man was my dad emilio martinez who
was also trying to get home the sign
said that he had van and he was looking
for six people who needed a ride to
colorado and joyce was one of the seven
total that trusted him to get back home
wow wow wow
it's your dad's legacy i mean what a
beautiful story that that's how he's
going to be remembered by complete
strangers
yeah it is amazing how two strangers
from two different cities they're
they're both from colorado but she was
going to chicago he was coming back from
ohio and how they they cross paths and
they came together during a time of need
i was so happy to hear that joyce is
doing well
and especially the fact that she still
thinks of the kindness that my dad
showed her on that day it meant so much
to me and i was just so touched and i
think i have a new friend now
i just get goosebumps mercedes because
you think of you know the fact that
this happened and that you were able to
find it on social media i guess it just
speaks to the power that social media
can do for good and wow wow wow wow
yeah and i really want to thank you guys
for helping get the word out you you and
john were the first people i talked to
about this uh the story on television
and i really feel like just the power
that that you had and it turned into
other stations talking to me and and we
were able to find one not seven but one
and that's all i needed that is like i
said the legacy of your father mercedes
what a beautiful story i am so happy for
you and your family to be able to find
this uh this one out of seven thank you
thank you so much we love chatting with
you have a great weekend
you too take care